do you ever have nightmares about like
gee i almost turned down better call
saul like i think there was a point
where you said after breaking bad
when they said hey i did say no to it
and my kids convinced me to do it
i just and i knew we were going to shoot
in albuquerque and i just thought i just
can't do it it's just they're they're
two years too young
they were probably 14 and 12.
so i just felt that i couldn't do it so
i
said no it was a funny weekend howard
because i got the call on friday night
do you are you gonna do it i said no
and then i got a call on sunday morning
from my manager mark and my wife is my
manager too but in this case in a
situation like this she had taken
herself out of the decision she said bob
if you want to do it
do it we'll make it work here at home
it'll be okay
if you don't want to do it you don't
have to do it whatever you want
i'm going to stay out of this choice and
she did she
stayed completely out of it and uh mark
called me on a sunday morning and he
goes
so i'm getting a call from sony uh
they're kind of
sunday morning are you sure you're
saying
no to this is it a real no
and he was right to ask you know and and
i said uh
yeah i i just don't think my kids are
old enough i can't leave for that length
of time
and it was a conversation and the kids
were walking around they heard me
and i hang up and i go uh my son looks
at me and he goes
so dad you're not gonna do that show and
i go
no son i i'm not i don't think we're
ready for that
and he goes well you're gonna disappoint
a lot of people
and i go well i said well i'm going to
disappoint a lot of strangers
and he goes well some of them are my
friends
wow and then we talked about it
and uh and he goes dad we'll make it
work you know it'll be okay
and and we'll help out and
and so then later in the day my daughter
and i i was taking her somewhere and she
had also heard from my
son and she goes you should do that show
and she's
she's an amazing kid my daughter erin
and she uh
kid grew grew up in hollywood right
because she goes
she says this to me dad
if you were to do the show how bad
if it was bad how bad would it be
and i go well it wouldn't be bad
it would it could be a misfire that's
the worst it could be
because these are great writers vince
gilligan peter gould and that team
there's going to be some excellence in
there just even
on their worst day and uh so i told her
at the worst it would be an interesting
experiment
and she you know she said you should do
it and so on monday
here i go to call my manager and then i
get a call from him first
and the deal's going up
and i'm already gonna say yes
ah keep quiet keep quiet